aber auch ein anderes thema beschäftigt
deutschlands seit dem wochenende es ist
die krawall nach von stuttgart die nacht
der schande und vor allem die frage wie
es dazu kommen konnte was die menschen
eben diese gewaltexzesse dann in der
nacht von samstag auf sonntag in
stuttgart ausgelebt haben
da darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
dem kriminologen professor doktor
christian pfeiffer ist mir jetzt live
zugeschaltet herr professor norbert
pfeiffer wenn sie die aufnahmen von
samstagnacht 10 aus stuttgart was denken
sie ist der grund dafür gewesen dass es
zu dieser extremen gewalt gekommen ist
ich sehe zwei faktoren zum einen dass
hier corona verlierer ihren frust
ausgelebt haben der sich über monate
angestaut hat das zweite eine kampagne
gegen die deutsche polizei die den
frustrierten corona verlierern die
richtung gewiesen hat ran an die bullen
die zusammenschlagen denen zeigen dass
wir stärker sind das könnten die beiden
ausgangssituationen gewesen sein
corona also ein großer faktor denken sie
man hat vor allem auch viel darüber
diskutiert dass die menschen die man
jetzt in diesen videos in den aufnahmen
sieht als als partyvolk als party
menschen beschrieben worden sind glauben
sie dass das eine zu zu freundliche
beschreibung noch von den menschen ist
die dort jetzt so hart gegen polizisten
und auch gegen andere gegenstände gegen
leben vorgegangen sind
eindeutig ja also das mit als party
folgt zu bezeichnen das wird nicht dem
gerecht was hier an gewaltexzess vorher
in den köpfen schon ein wut da war und
wie sich das dann ausgelebt hat also da
muss man schon ein bisschen tiefer
hinschauen
leider stehen ja noch nicht die daten
fest der menschen die jetzt verhaftet
wurden und es ist ohnehin nur ein
kleiner ausschnitt derjenigen um die es
geht aber die vermutung erscheint schon
berechtigt das corona die armen im lande
doppelt getroffen hat
denn wer davor der hand im mund liebte
als schwarzarbeiter in irgend einer
kneipe
auf dem bau oder sonst wo er hat ja kein
kurzarbeit geld gekriegt der war
plötzlich ganz schnell pleite und
schiebt frust vor sich hin
dann kommt hinzu junge männer brauchen
aus tore schossen am freitagnacht bis 3
uhr früh tanzen oder beim fußballclub
drei mal in der woche in der c-klasse
trainieren all das ist ausgeschlossen
das heißt da hat sich ganz viel
angestaut an körperlichen bedürfnissen
aber auch eben an aggression dass man
sich ungerecht behandelt sieht ich sage
nicht dass das entschuldigen soll aber
es erklärt ein bisschen was sie hier
zusammengebracht hat bei der clique wie
sich da immer am freitag oder am
samstagabend getroffen hat und bei viel
bier ihren eigenen frust bekämpft hat
ein professor pfeiffer für ihre
einschätzung dankeschön